je crois que c'est tout un délire sur la
cancel culture aujourd'hui à
l'université qui est à qui n'existent
pas en réalité on débat voyez moi dans
mon laboratoire g stephan peau qui n'est
pas exactement sur les mêmes positions
que point séminaire bien on pourra
échanger sur nos points de vue et donc
regarder comment il est vivement ça se
fasse à l'université s'ils se rendre
compte que les questions dont on a parlé
ce soir des travaux sur les questions
raciales demeure extrêmement minoritaire
et sont loin de constituer la majorité
des recherches en sciences sociales
c'est pas quelque chose de bankable
aujourd'hui comme on l'entend parfois de
travailler sur ces questions et au
contraire c'est parfois coûteux il ya
peu de financements de recherche ya peu
de postes et donc il faut voir il faut
regarder ça à mon avis beaucoup plu à
beaucoup plus froidement et dernier mot
peut-être quand bien même il n'y a pas
de quand cette culture à l'université
moi je ne vois pas du tout cela dans ma
pratique quotidienne je crois que c'est
quand même important aussi de se dire
qu'il peut être intéressant de laisser
un peu de place à des points de vue qui
ont été longtemps minorisées où un
physique à l'université moi en tant qu
homme blanc pas que je laisse un peu de
place à des collègues femmes que je
laisse de la place à des collègues
racisées pour faire part de leur
expérience qu'elle puisse avoir aussi
leur mot à dire au sein de l'université
française ça me semble sain et en tant
que tel laisser un peu plus de place
je ne me sens pas annulé one il est dans
ma liberté d'expression
[Musique]